[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a Europa hoy el
programa de actualidad Europea de France
24 en español yo soy Esther Herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en Bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy abordamos los derechos de las
personas de la comunidad lgtbi en la
Unión Europea se ha avanzado suficiente
o persiste la discriminación Y qué
ocurre en países como Polonia y Hungría
antes de pasar al debate hacemos un
breve repaso a la situación en los 27 la
discriminación sexual y la protección de
los Derechos Humanos están consagrados
en el derecho europeo pese a ello la
discriminación contra las personas gays
lesbianas bisexuales o transexuales
persisten en la Unión Europea entre los
27 países del bloque 18 reconocen las
uniones del mismo sexo en una sentencia
del tribunal de justicia de la Unión
Europea se exigió que todos los
matrimonios y uniones civiles se
reconozcan en cualquier país europeo
aunque no en todo sea legal en la última
encuesta sobre Derechos de las minorías
76% de los europeos consideran que la
comunidad lgtbi debe tener los mismos
derechos que los heterosexuales pero
mientras que en países como Suecia llega
al 98% esa afirmación solo así lo
considera un 31% en Eslovaquia las
personas que más sufren son las
transexuales más del 60% reportan algún
tipo de discriminación a lo largo de su
vida además hay preocupación sobre la
regresión de derechos en países como
Polonia donde existen pueblos
denominados libres de ideología lgtbi
por esta razón la comisión europea ha
retirado fondos y ha abierto un
procedimiento de infracción también lo
ha hecho con Hungría aquí en Bruselas se
llevó ante la justicia europea en julio
tras la aprobación de una ley en la que
se prohíbe a los menores estar expuestos
en películas o libros a contenido que
haga referencia a la comunidad lgtbi una
muestra más de que los derechos
fundamentales no pueden por conquistados
tampoco en el bloque europeo
y para analizarlo tenemos con nosotros a
las eurodiputadas Rosa estarás del
partido popular europeo bienvenida Rosa
Hola Muchas gracias y con Soraya
Rodríguez del grupo renovar Europa
Muchas gracias muchas gracias a ti
gracias a las dos por estar aquí las
personas lgtbi están protegidas en la
carta de derechos fundamentales de la
Unión Europea en que se prohíbe
explícitamente la discriminación en base
a la orientación sexual pero aún así la
discriminación persiste en la Unión
Europea se ha avanzado pero no lo
suficiente qué es lo que ocurre Rosa Por
qué bueno está claro que la letra de lo
que es el corazón de Europa la clave son
los derechos humanos y los derechos de
las personas y del colectivo lgtbi son
derechos humanos están protegidos en la
letra pero luego la realidad tristemente
a veces no se corresponde con todo lo
que se ha estipulado como valores
humanos
hay discriminación en la golpea está
luchando para que no la haya y de hecho
ha probado recientemente una estrategia
europea para el colectivo lgtbi
2020-2030 pero después de la pandemia
hemos podido ver que todavía esto ha ido
un poco en aumento y que últimamente nos
está preocupando mucho la proliferación
de delitos de odio contra este colectivo
y de hecho hace poquito tuvimos un
debate en estrasburgo después de los
acontecimientos en bratislava de la
muerte de dos chicos que eran del
colectivo lgtbi por parte de un chico de
19 años
extremista y radicalizado que los mato a
tiros entonces tuvimos un debate donde
pedimos prácticamente todos los que
tenemos sentido común que se incluyan
los delitos de odio contra este
colectivo como Euro delito en el
artículo 83 del tratado de la unión
queda mucho por hacer yo veo con
preocupación como y de hecho hay un
debate mañana por la mañana sobre temas
de discriminación y lo mismo como
todavía
hay que lucharlo porque todavía hay una
proliferación de delitos de odia contra
este colectivo pero también contra el
colectivo de judíos musulmanes Y todavía
hay por desgracia mucho que trabajar y
mucho que hacer
qué es lo que motiva a esta
discriminación porque se está
produciendo hay como él comentaba Rosa
Este asesinato brutal contra dos jóvenes
en Eslovaquia sí efectivamente este
asesinato brutal que nos conmovió a
todos y provocó también aquí en el
parlamento europeo el debate y la
propuesta que acaba de citarrosa
lamentablemente es un hecho más de lo
que está sucediendo en la Unión Europea
en relación a los derechos del colectivo
lgtbiq porque muy A diferencia de lo que
de lo que deberíamos estar hoy hablando
del Avance en la eliminación de la
discriminación tenemos que constatar que
estamos en claro en Franco retroceso
según el último análisis de la agencia
de la Unión Europea de derechos
fundamentales en el 2019 más del 53% de
las personas de este colectivo Se
sentían discriminadas habían sido
acosadas de forma directa o indirecta
mientras que en 2012 este esta cifra era
del 37%, por lo tanto del 37 al 53%. en
Eslovaquia donde sucedió este último
hidramático acontecimiento el incremento
de personas acosadas se ha incrementado
de 1 a 10 en el colectivo lgtbiq porque
sucede esto porque
en estados de la Unión Europea se está
legislando en contra de este colectivo
tenemos el caso de Polonia en Polonia el
año pasado se declararon y se adhirieron
100 municipios a una aberración desde el
punto de vista de los derechos
fundamentales de cualquier ciudadano
europeo municipios libres de lgtbiq de
colectivos el parlamento reaccionó
nombrando este parlamento este espacio
como un espacio de libertad para el
colectivo Pero esto está pasando en
Polonia está pasando también en Hungría
hemos visto declaraciones de políticos
importantes en Bulgaria declaraciones
claramente
xenófobas contra este colectivo por lo
tanto esto Esta realidad terrible Se
produce porque efectivamente está viendo
un Claro retroceso en legislaciones
nacionales no solamente en la protección
de los Derechos sino en leyes en
actuaciones desde las desde los poderes
públicos que van claramente en contra de
la discriminación que por otra parte es
estructural llevan años sufriendo esta
discriminación no podemos olvidar que
hoy en Naciones Unidas en 69 estados de
Naciones Unidas el tener cualquier tipo
de acto sexual con sentido entre
personas del mismo sexo sigue siendo
considerado un crimen en muchos países
un gravísimo crimen
castigado con pena severas por lo tanto
Esta es una realidad terrible que yo
creo que hay que analizar de forma Clara
para poder adoptar las medidas
necesarias para frenarlo Y para revertir
esta situación precisamente eso ahí
hacías mención a Polonia y Hungría la
comisión europea
ha abierto procedimientos de infracción
también ha llevado a Hungría ante la
justicia europea pero está haciendo la
comisión europea lo suficiente como para
atacar estas legislaciones a las que
hacía mención Soraya Sí a ver en el caso
de Polonia en Hungría ha habido un
flagrante ataque al Estado de derecho y
ha habido muchas resoluciones para que
el artículo 7 que hemos abierto a estos
dos estados que es cuando un estado no
está con los valores europeos se active
el procedimiento por lo tanto en lo que
con los instrumentos legales que tenemos
se está haciendo lo que se tiene que
hacer es verdad que para mí con cierta
lentitud y de hecho hemos demandado que
esto se agilizara lo decías Soraya el
que en El Siglo 21
alguien se le ocurra decir que hay
calles
barrios donde no puede circular una
persona por su orientación sexual o la
identidad sexual es surrealista Es que
no es posible es que no cabe en la
cabeza pero está pasando está pasando
Pues en Polonia varios municipios están
en varias calles en varios barrios están
prohibidos de personas lgtbi y se han
quedado tan anchos Entonces nosotros
siempre que pasa esto reaccionamos la
presidenta salió enseguida y todo el
parlamento a decir que no que nosotros
aquí no descansaremos hasta que
conseguir que todas las personas puedan
circular libremente por el mundo
independientemente de su raza resolución
de su orientación o de su identidad
sexual y estamos cada día haciendo
bandera de los Derechos Humanos porque
es lo que nos caracteriza Europa es el
continente de los derechos humanos y es
verdad que también la comisión aprobó
esta estrategia que os he dicho que es
la primera estrategia y además anima
esta estrategia europea del colectivo
lgtbi anima a todos los estados miembros
a todos los ayuntamientos a todas las
regiones a publicar su propia estrategia
lgtbi impregnar todo aquello que vayamos
decidiendo tanto si hablamos de vivienda
de educación de trabajo de salud de
Justicia siempre impregnar la visión
arcoiris de una visión en todo lo que
hagamos que simbolice que estamos
pensando en que hagamos lo que hagamos
siempre en igual y el no discriminación
de hecho la propia estrategia habla de
que no vayamos a discriminar de que haya
seguridad que Europa sea un sitio seguro
donde tú no te sientas en ningún momento
ni acosaron ni discriminado por tu
orientación y En tercer lugar que la
educación no sea estereotipada que no se
eduquen en valores que nos eduquen en el
respeto que en el trabajo no haya los
obstáculos que hay para este colectivo
en la salud y luego ya hago una
interminable
temas de sobre todo de igualdad no lo
tenemos mucho tiempo pero ahora que
recojo el guante de rosas sobre esta
estrategia de la comisión europea pero
se trata un poco de pedir a los estados
que hagan Pero le falta ambición Porque
muchos estados como comentabas no lo
están haciendo sino que están regresando
Sí yo creo que tenemos que ser mucho más
enérgicos con
aquellos estados que legislan en contra
de los derechos de este colectivo o que
legislan en contra de las mujeres Esto
está pasando
Es cierto que dimos un paso importante y
que el tribunal de Justicia europeo
avaló la suspensión de fondos para
aquellos estados que no cumplieran el
estado de derecho y quiero significar
una cosa la separación de poderes es
fundamental para el Estado de derecho
pero el respeto de los derechos
fundamentales de los y de las ciudadanas
europeas es el corazón de Europa y no
puede existir un estado que asuma el
acervo del Estado de derecho y esté
legislando en contra de estos derechos
Es verdad que Polonia ha estado sin
recibir fondos igual que Hungría pero
recientemente la comisión en junio ha
liberado más de 35.400 millones de euros
de los fondos de recuperación Mientras
tanto en este país siguen siguen
manteniéndose normas claramente
xenófobas racistas de aparthei a las
personas por de su identidad sexual
sigue habiendo legislación que
normalmente coincide es antigénero Es
decir anti contra las mujeres contra
este colectivo y se sigue haciendo
claramente dando subvenciones también
asociaciones que hacen discursos contra
este colectivo nos quedamos con esta
idea gracias a Soraya también a ti rosas
disculpad nos hemos quedado sin tiempo a
ustedes les esperamos en el próximo
programa de Europa hoy Gracias por ver
France 24 en español
[Música]